that's like the burnt skin the grafted
skin
and then
this is where they connect the skin
together that scar
this is the other side
because this is actually my real skin
and it actually like kind of matches the
donor skin pretty good
[Music]
i had a 2014 challenger rt
and i i've had a bunch of upgrades on it
i guess i got i was leaving work
it's like six o'clock in the morning
and that's just driving i just fell
asleep at the wheel and
just reared off the road and hit a curb
and a car flipped i think three times i
was told
and it caught on fire
all i remember is just waking up in the
hospital and didn't really tell me
anything he's telling me i looked good
and
you know when i when they certainly
looked good i felt like yeah
it probably looked like the old me you
know the same
but in their returns i looked good
medically so i wasn't going for like
three and a half months i did that for
i was doing like two surgeries a week
which is pretty rare
uh because usually you have to give give
me a break and stuff on i guess i was i
was young and athletic
so they didn't have to give me a break
my body was just taking it like pretty
good they took the skin mostly from my
back
thighs
uh
my my right arm and put it on my
my left arm
my chest and like
my calves the doctors told me that my
burns are like eighty percent
on my body
which in that meal that's pretty rare
for someone to have you know to survive
that first time i saw him the first time
i saw myself
i think i was in
the rehab we had
to get back to normal in a way i was
wasn't really emotional and didn't cry
about it but
i was more
like like interested on how a skin could
look like that because i never saw a
burnt person before or
you know except like freddy krueger but
that's not like realistic
i didn't want to be like oh
i look so bad and
i'm not gonna kneel
i'm not gonna do anything about it so i
just
i just stuck to the workouts they're
giving me to
to get out of the hospital to get out
yeah the rehab
i had you know dr regas was very like
down thirth guy who
you know i just had a lot of trust me
when i first met him i think
that really did it for me
the surgery took
a good 24 hours and then
after the surgery i didn't wake up after
the surgery they uh
they kept me sedated for a good week
so i couldn't move or nothing
so i wouldn't mess up like the surgery
in a way
yeah everything was fragile uh
he only flexing the muscles or you know
it could tear a tendon i guess after
waking up it was just like
oh the occupational therapies jumped
right in
there's like no time for me to like you
know just like relax as soon as i woke
up ot's came in like an hour later just
stretching my hands out doing exercises
and like
i couldn't even move my fingers at the
time you know just a little wiggle
i lost my eyelids
so i couldn't blink so they covered it
in a way
so it was like looking at a fence
but i don't the only one way i lost the
vision lost
a little bit more like my vision is
because of the fire but
i can still see like you know i see
everything i just can't read small text
messages or but i can you know drive and
everything
the whole hardest thing was you know
with the hands
picking up things uh
you know picking it like just picking
like a bur like a cheeseburger it's hard
because you know
i don't have all i can't like
individually put down my fingers but so
one side always comes out of the other
so i can't really have tomatoes on it
but i do like the lettuce on it though
so like
picking up one thing and having it fall
off the other side you know
thousand trying to get that down right
and then
just like the small things people don't
realize that you do like you know keys
if you're uh taking out your credit
cards your wallet
like
this is the right hand looks like
after like the burnt skin the grafted
skin
and then
this is where they connect the skin
together that scar
this is the other side
so that this is actually my real skin
and it actually like kind of matches the
donor skin pretty good
and then the left side
is a lot worse with the burns
so that's all the burnt skin right there
and you know that side
too
it leaves me more patient
a lot more patient because i was pretty
like
get a done guy but now it's like i gotta
wait and
can't do things right away so you know
it takes me a while to get things done
because of my my hands like
you only live once so like
generally change it i just keep living
keep moving forward it was i guess it
wasn't my time
i just i just kept going forward i don't
know everyone everyone handles it
differently and like my my thing was
just keep moving don't think about
how you look
or because everyone's going to look at
you no matter how you look so it's like
don't really think about don't really
think of that because they're going to
look at even if you had your normal skin
they still looked at you
so it's like who cares if
you know they're just gonna look at you
more
and in my eyes
uh if if someone looked like me i would
stare too so it
didn't really bother me
uh we met on instagram i i
read his story because my old college
professor sent it to me
and my first initial thought was man
that sucks because he was really hot
before right exactly my type i was like
that was my first thought like you know
he went from
being such a handsome young guy to you
know going through all of this
and i didn't think much of it and i was
re i was watching youtube because it
helps me go to sleep
and i saw his story again and i was like
i'm gonna add him on instagram because i
can and i'm curious and i'm a nosy
person by nature
uh so i added him uh and we have the
same dog breed uh so he he messaged me
first
and said i like your dog and then it
kind of just
unfolded from there we just talked every
day
we talked on the phone no one could
survive what he's gone through you know
it's not something that's easy medically
it's it's impossible
um it's a miracle that he's here so i
think for him to go through everything
he's gone through but maintain a
positive
and ambitious outlook is really rare
like
every day it inspires me and you know i
try to tell other people to so that they
keep going moving forward
i distinctively remember
one night where
my appearance was beginning to
drastically change and more and more
veins were starting to show up on the
right side of my face i like went into
my bathroom got a towel wet it and just
started wiping my face because i was
like this can't be my life